how's it going everybody there is a lot
of hype right now in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and just outside the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as well with
venom coming out we have Captain Marvel
coming out
spider-man far from home coming out as
well and of course Avengers 4 which
still does not have an official title
but there has been a lot of leaks
concerning Avengers 4 and some official
promo art has been released as well and
of course they have left us with some
questions and today we're going to be
asking why is Hulk wearing a suit I'm
still doing my giveaway giving away a
few copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray some special edition posters and
some special edition memorabilia all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so in this first official
promo art photo that was released for
Avengers 4 we got a new look at some of
the characters and one thing that really
stood out to some people is that the
Hulk is wearing a suit now some people
are saying that he's wearing this suit
because it's custom made and it won't
rip when Bruce Banner turns into the
Hulk this makes sense but they've never
worried about this in any of the other
movies so why would they start to worry
about it now and if they did they
wouldn't make it the main focus of this
suit I personally think that it has
everything to do with Professor Hulk
I've talked about Professor Hulk in a
few videos if you want a super deep
breakdown of him you can check out a
video in the link above and I'll also
put it at the end of this video but to
quickly go over who Professor Hulk is
it's basically Bruce Banner and the Hulk
combined as one person not to separate
people so it's the Hulk's body with
banners mind there is a lot that
suggests that we're going to see
professor Hulk in Avengers 4 Mark
Ruffalo himself even stated after thor
ragnarok but before Avengers infinity
war that the line between Bruce Banner
and Hulk is beginning to get a little
blurry and although the Hulk and Bruce
Banner didn't exactly have the best
relationship in Avengers infinity war
half of the universe got wiped away from
existence so they're going to have to
put their differences aside
if they want to have any chance at
defeating Thanos where's your gun
I don't know sugar about having a thing
it's no time for a thing
so again why the suit well I think it
serves a very important purpose for
Professor Hulk primarily Bruce Banner
side so even though Bruce Banner needed
the Hulk at the end of Thor Ragnarok and
an infinity war we all know that he's
afraid to turn back into the Hulk out of
fear that the Hulk will take over and
he'll never be able to turn back into
banner and this is where apart from
Professor Hulk storyline and the Comics
comes into play in the comics Bruce
Banner subconsciously puts a safeguard
and professor Hulk and what this does is
when Hulk gets too mad and too angry it
automatically reverts him back to Bruce
Banner so I think this safeguard in the
comics that is a subconscious safeguard
is actually the suit that we see in the
leaked concept art photo I think the
suit is the safeguard I think the suit
has some sort of capability designed to
where if the Hulk gets too angry it will
automatically revert him back to Bruce
Banner this is something him and Tony
could easily come up with especially
with Tony's nanotechnology and we saw
how thin and flexible it could be on
spider-man in Avengers infinity war and
if you take a look at the concept art
nobody else is wearing a suit like this
it's just Hulk so I think that if it was
something that is ridiculously awesome
that could be used in combat everybody
would have it or at least more than just
one person and again I don't think they
do this just for the sheer fact that
it's clothing that could expand with him
as he becomes the Hulk and as he goes
back to Bruce Banner
they've never cared before so it just
doesn't make sense for them to care now
so I do think that this is some way some
safeguard for Bruce Banner to be able to
turn into the Hulk but not have to worry
about the Hulk taking over and never be
in banner again I think this is the safe
garden and this way Banner and Hulk sort
of fight together not as two different
people we learned after infinity war
came out that the reason the Hulk would
not come out is because he was tired of
fighting all of Bruce's battles for him
and again professor Hulk is the mind of
Banner but the body of the Hulk so it
wouldn't be the Hulk doing all the
fighting they'd be working together so
it would make sense that he'd come out
but of course Bruce would obviously
still be
scared that he'd never be able to turn
back into Bruce Banner completely so
they put this safeguard which I'm saying
is the suit let me know what you all
think about this do you think that
Professor Hulk is coming and that this
suit could be the safeguard or do you
think it's something completely
different and unrelated let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
and again another reminder about the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero thank you
all so much for watching look for
[Music]